quand j'appelle ma faim le 16 mars en
fait à quatre heures je suis dit inquiet
de pause j'ai pris un tir dvd dans
l'oeil mais c'est rien moi je savais en
fait déjà épris de tirs que j'ai perdu
mon oeil j'arrive pas à remonter cette
cette colère en fait que jean membre
j'ai envie de me en l'air tous
les jours
[Musique]
je me suis retrouvé en plein milieu de
la rue des champs au niveau de la
hauteur des du fouquet's non en fait je
me suis retrouvé là je me suis dit tiens
c'est bon j'ai assez prix de gaz
j'étais plus fatigué qu'autre chose et
je me dis tiens je me mets tant avec la
foule et quand ils commencent à prendre
feu je tourne la tête et je prends tire
d'aile bd je sais pas d'où ça vient
[Musique]
je suis clan en charge par le gaz par
dessus on fait du coup andrew bascule un
peu plus loin il regarde par dessus je
suis il transporte au moins deux
trophées
ils ont réussi à me sortir mais le
départ le barrage de la police en fait
tu voulais pas me laisser sortir de ma
bulle en trombe ce que tu voulais pas
laisser sortir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prends contact ensemble il ya un hôpital
pour démarrer la procédure
l'enquète a commencé et tout et j'ai été
convoqué au mali j'ai peine six mois
après ses balles et gipn en fait à
essayer de me faire dire comme cox était
pas un et nous aider jdsu sa/nv des j'en
suis persuadé sa peau talk et aux
caisses vu le tir en fait qui est tendu
donc c'est tout après six mois après en
fait bas de six banques
[Musique]
convoqué au point tu as et lui valut la
truite sur en même pas un an
il ya quatre ans deux mois deux mois
comme annoncé ça et alors que le gipn a
rien trouvé
quand on veut on peut
[Musique]
je suivis par un psychologue ça fait pas
longtemps ça fait deux ans que j'ai ma
tête elle a envie de en fait j'ai envie
de me en l'air
tous les jours je suis pas au boulot
j'ai 70 km en tout à faire en voiture
tout seul j'arrive pas à monter le truc
j'arrive pas à remonter cette cette
colère en fait que j'ai en moi j'ai la
haine de ça en fait j'ai la haine de
tout ce qui se passe j'ai la haine de
tout leur connerie j'ai donc depuis deux
ans je vis pas
[Musique]
moi j'ai de la chance
d'avoir été embauchés avant j'ai cette
chance par rapport à tous les mutilés la
plupart qui arrivent par trouver du
boulot mais c'était très compliqué de me
remettre en fait dedans on s'énerve vite
et en perd patience et on n'a plus
confiance en lui mais en fait moi
j'avais plus du tout confiance en moi
c'est le moment que tu reprends ton
boulot que tu connais depuis longtemps
die même par faire ça tu es complètement
perdus en fait
je rentre de l'hôpital mercy qui se mord
ampleur c'est une image en fait depuis
deux ans elle est encore dans ma tête
dans ma fille sarah c'est pas une fille
à s'expliquer elle est allé très très
réservée tout en restant fermés on parle
pas trop avec sa femme parce qu'on est
pas trop le chercher depuis deux ans que
c'est pesant pour elle qui qui a fait
beaucoup d'efforts qui me laissait les
manifester pour la famille me revois
repartir à paris c'est pas évident
[Musique]
gm est pays maintenance et du dégoût en
fait on tire sur le peuple jean michel
naud peuvent le peuple on on incarcère
des personnes qui ont rien fait on tue
des personnes comme steve eysines et les
drones
donc ouais j'ai un dégoût de la france
en fait je me sens plus chez moi